هذا هو صوت
رئيس المخابرات الداخلية الإسرائيلية في
تسجيل حصلت عليه قناة K
TV الإسرائيلية وهو يتعهد بالقضاء على حماس
بغض النظر عن مكان تواجدهم، وقد
حدد لنا مجلس الوزراء هدفًا على حد
تعبير الشارع وهو القضاء على
حماس و  نحن مصممون على القيام بذلك في
كل مكان في غزة، إسرائيل، لبنان، تركيا،
قطر في
كل مكان
رداً على تركيا التي استضافت
قادة حماس قبل أن تصدر تحذيراً
بحسب المسؤولين الذين تحدثوا مع
وكالة أنباء الأناضول الرسمية، وستكون هناك
عواقب وخيمة إذا حاولت إسرائيل
تنفيذ اغتيالات في
تركيا  يُظهر هذا التبادل الأخير إلى أي
مدى تراجعت العلاقة بين
البلدين منذ بدء الحرب، بدءًا
من المصافحة الأولى على الإطلاق
بين الرئيس أردوغان ورئيس
الوزراء نتنياهو في سبتمبر/أيلول، وصولاً إلى
تصريحات مثل هذه بعد أسابيع فقط،
فحماس ليست
منظمة إرهابية، بل هي جماعة تحرير
يكافح من أجل حماية أرضه
ومواطنيه أقول بكل وضوح وصراحة
أن إسرائيل
دولة إرهابية نتنياهو جزار غزة
أبعد من كونه مجرم حرب سيحاكم
بالتأكيد كجزار غزة
تماما كما قال نتنياهو
الشهر الماضي أن إسرائيل  يرفض أي محاضرات
من تركيا قائلاً إن أردوغان يدعم
دولة حماس الإرهابية ويقصف
القرى التركية داخل تركيا نفسها، في
إشارة إلى حربها المستمرة منذ عقود
ضد المسلحين الأكراد، فهم يكرهون بعضهم
البعض إلى أي مدى أدت هذه الحرب إلى تحسين
العلاقات التركية الإسرائيلية طالما ظل
BB  وأردوغان في السلطة، لا
أعتقد أنهما سيلتقيان مرة أخرى. تعود العلاقات إلى
أكثر من 70 عامًا عندما
أصبحت تركيا أول دولة ذات أغلبية مسلمة
تعترف بدولة إسرائيل التي تم تشكيلها حديثًا،
لكن القضية الفلسطينية كانت دائمًا
نقطة حساسة، وقد خرجت العلاقات عن مسارها.  في عام 2010، بعد
مقتل تسعة أتراك وأميركي من أصل تركي على يد القوات الإسرائيلية على متن
أسطول مساعدات في طريقه إلى
غزة منذ بدء الحرب، شهدت تركيا
مسيرات ضخمة مؤيدة للفلسطينيين، قادها الرئيس نفسه،
وقام الرئيس أردوغان بقطع
الاتصالات رسميًا مع رئيس الوزراء.
كما استدعى الوزير نتنياهو وتركيا
سفيرهما إلى إسرائيل، لكن لا تزال هناك
تجارة سنوية بمليارات الدولارات بين تركيا وإسرائيل،
ولم تنته العلاقات التجارية، تواصل
الرحلات الجوية،
تستمر في نقل النفط إلى
إسرائيل عبر المضيق لفترة طويلة.  نظرًا لأن
تركيا وإسرائيل تعتقدان أنهما
بحاجة إلى بعضهما البعض من الناحية الاستراتيجية،
إلا أن العلاقات السياسية قد
تستمر، وقد ظل بعض الأتراك العاديين والمؤسسات يقاطعون
علنًا
العلامات التجارية التي لها صلات مزعومة
بإسرائيل، وتقول تركيا إنه منذ بداية
الحرب انخفضت التجارة بنسبة أكبر  أكثر من
النصف مدفوع من قبل المستهلكين والتجار
وليس أي
عقوبات رسمية، وعلى الرغم من
الغضب المتزايد والخطاب الناري،
يصر أردوغان على أن تركيا لا تزال قادرة على التوسط في
السلام. ما يسعى إليه هو أن يكون شريكًا
في أي حل، ولا يبدو
وكأنه وصف إسرائيل بأنها إرهابية.  من
المرجح أن الدولة تعتقد أنه يستطيع
التراجع عن حقيقة أنه لم يذهب بعيدًا،
وأشك في أنه يفكر بهذه الطريقة سواء كان
الآخرون يفكرون بهذه الطريقة أم لا، سنرى
عندما تنتهي هذه الحرب